et univoque et
sidney poitier fracasse le plafond de
verre en 1964 en devenant le premier
homme noir à remporter l'oscar du
meilleur acteur sa prestation dans le
liste deschamps lui vaut les grands
honneurs
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer poitiers
j'ai été émue un peu comme j'étais ému
lorsque maurice richard et décider parce
que je sais ce qu'il est capable
né d'une famille humble aux bahamas rien
ne le prédestinait à hollywood il migre
aux états unis à l'âge de 15 ans et
intègre l'actor studio une prestigieuse
école de théâtre c'est l'acteur a
préféré de ma grand mère ma mère la
première fois qu'elle a été au cinéma en
haïti c'était aux comiques de demain
donc pour moi c'était quelque chose
c'était quelqu'un que j'ai toujours
changer être comme lui
avec une cinquantaine de films à son
actif il campe le rôle d'un médecin noir
dans une amérique blanche transgressant
les codes sociaux des états unis des
années 1950 l'acteur embrasse la cause
des droits civiques aux états unis et
incarne même le personnage de nelson
mandela en 1997 quand il est arrivé à
hollywood où tout début des années 50 il
disait volontiers il tenait un premier
rôle dans un film qu'il était là où il
travaillait le seul noir avec le cireur
de chaussures il reçoit en 2019 la
médaille présidentielle de la liberté
des mains de barack obama la plus haute
distinction aux états-unis
- cliché en cliché mais il faut
s'inspirer de ce que déjà comme siné
poitiers ont fait il ya quelques
générations pour continuer de marcher
vers une plus grande égalité vers une
plus grande reconnaissance
aujourd'hui
il sait jean philippe yllouz radio
canada montréal
[Musique]